c'est la fin d'une époque
andré ménard et alain simard quitte le
festival international de jazz de
montréal fondée il ya quarante ans pas
de modestie le suspense on a fait partie
d'une époque je parlais des récentes on
était plus que des témoins ont été des
acteurs
c'est sûr que bon dans tout ce que j'ai
fait le festival de jazz par mais ce
qu'il est devenu c'est sans doute ma
plus grande fierté gérant et producteur
alain simard a présenté dans les années
70 des concerts de genesis gentle giant
et pink floyd et après avoir organisé
tous ces spectacles il a l'idée de créer
ce qui deviendra le plus important
festival de jazz au monde et c'est le
début des arbitres prise de conscience
et je me dis montréal bon pas de langues
français anglais nos problèmes alors je
fais rire de moi beaucoup le disant que
c'est attirer des touristes n'a pas bien
d'entrevue d'ailleurs avec jean pierre
ferland dans une émission et pourquoi ne
marchera jamais producteurs dans les
années 70 andré ménard s'est associé à
alain simard et adonis mais cannes pour
créer l'équipe spectra et le festival de
jazz en 40 ans il a cumulé les bons
coups donc le grand concert gratuit de
stevie wonder et les spectacles de mark
davies sur le programme on a une image
et sur les couvertures cette année là
mais pas sur métaux portrait d'une photo
on l'appelait le dernier rempart à bien
par an par un bon allez visionner pour
avec son quartier des spectacles et tous
ces festivals organisés par l'équipe
spectra montréal s'est imposé comme
métropole culturelle allait se marier
andré ménard qui sont pour quelque chose
avant le festival de jazz n'est ce pas
cette nuit l'été à montréal même que
pendant des années le surnom de montréal
l'été c'était balconville
le festival de jazz survivra au départ
de ses deux cofondateurs puisque ceux ci
ont vendu il ya six ans leur entreprise
au groupe ch de jeff monson l'offre de
jeff monson est venu et je les accepte
et avec plaisir parce que c'est un
gentil a repris tout le respect dû à son
compte ce qui m'a permis d'avoir une
bonne retraite le plan de retraite de
vie comme ça je pense qu'ils n'existent
pas vraiment je peux les pressions je
veux continuer à faire quelques quelque
chose dans jade mais de pas au même
rythme n'est pas de la même façon
épris de culture allez simard et andré
ménard continueront de voyager et bien
sûr d'écouter beaucoup beaucoup de
musique ici louis fait depuis mai radio
canada montréal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]